au fait à tulsa lit le sedov modernisme
du lys apparu vers autre chose
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur passé
sauvage pour ce premier épisode de la
chronique intitulée la modernité késako
pourquoi avoir eu envie de tâter d'un
tel sujet eh bien il se trouve qu'en
septembre 2015 new york times publiait
un article intitulé twenty seven ways to
be e modern man dans lequel l'auteur
brian lombardie dresse une liste de 27
règles à suivre pour être un homme
moderne
donc voici quelques exemples le mec
moderne n'a jamais perdu de tweets ne le
fera jamais le mec moderne ne met pas de
côté les morceaux de gras de son steak
il déguste chaque bouchée de son burger
le mec moderne n'achète que du coca
normale et assume sa ligne le mec
moderne a sérieusement réfléchi acheter
un chausse pied le mec moderne à du
parquet dans son appart
depuis l'apparition de cet article la
question de ce qu'est la modernité m'a
laissé un peu
perplexe alors pas à cause des exemples
même car ils sont plutôt drôles et qui
sont présentés avec une ironie et qu'il
faut bien l'admettre il résume assez
bien certains aspects de nos vies
quotidiennes
ce que je remettrai en cause c'est le
cadre même de l'article édifié autour de
règles ce qui supposerait 4 moderne ce
n'est pas inné ça s'acquiert le mec
moderne n'achète que du coca jeu bah moi
non moi je ne bois pas de coca donc zéro
pour moi un pour brian d'assumer sa
ligne tant mieux pour lui un chausse
pied
mon père m'a en résumé si vous suivez
ses 27 règle vous êtes bon mais si vous
les suivez pas que se passe-t-il merci
brian voilà grâce à toi je sais que je
ne suis pas moderne alors je sais pas ce
que je suis vous est inexistant ou s'est
traduit mieux d'anciens carrément de
mort et c'est là que ça coince
parce qu'il n'ya pas de lois de la
modernité la modernité c'est une
idéologie perception que l'on se fait
des choses nouvelles par rapport à
celles du passé d'ailleurs la nuit entre
le passé le présent est très subjective
elle est propre à chacun ce qu'on va
tenter de faire danser vidéo c'est de
répondre à la question qu'est ce que la
modernité de la façon la plus globale
est la plus objective possible
en comparant des événements du passé à
nos modes de vie actuels et pour cela on
va faire référence aux sciences humaines
qui étudient l'homme en société
très bien mais avant d'aller plus loin
il faudrait regarder la définition d'un
dictionnaire une personne moderne est
une personne de son époque
voilà tout le problème avec cette
définition qui est tellement vague large
que l'on peut faire du terme moderne ce
que l'on veut et c'est bien ce qui se
passe avec l'article du new york times
l'adjectif moderne nogent essayer des
expressions comme style est cool hype
swag des anglicismes qui servent à
désigner de l'alluré charisme d'une
personne on est donc toujours coincés
dans le domaine de l'apparence de la
technologie et de la consommation ce qui
n'est pas faux en soi car la définition
populaire de l'homme et de la modernité
tourne autour de ces trois principes il
n'y a qu'à taper hommes modernes sur un
serveur de recherche et vous verrez tout
de suite de quoi je veux parler
le problème avec cette définition c'est
qu'elle est trop restrictive elle ne
s'habille pas tout le monde
on l'a vu avec les exemples précédents
j'assume
ne suis pas le dernier je ne suis pas de
mon époque c'est étrange mais j'accepte
la défaite brian qu'est ce qui se passe
si buvait pas de coca ne vous avez du
parquet vous portez des stan smith et
pas des nike ça n'a pas de sens donc il
faudrait qu'on trouve une définition qui
pourrait s'appliquer à tout le monde
si on peut pas se baser sur la mode et
les gadgets sur quoi peut on partir pour
réfléchir à ce qu'est la modernité à
partir de réflexion plus générale comme
par exemple notre façon de se loger de
travailler ou encore de se nourrir
on pourrait tout à fait envisager la
modernité via l'alimentation dans un
premier temps on va prendre pour
commencer un aliment de base quelque
chose que tout le monde connaît comme le
pain le pain nourrit l'homme depuis la
préhistoire est toujours à la base de
repas dans de nombreux pays c'est
quelque chose dont on connaît les
méthodes de fabrication anciennes et les
méthodes les plus actuels donc on va
pouvoir comparer ces deux modes de
fabrication et voir quel impact ont eu
la modernisation et les progrès
techniques sur le pain au cours de
l'histoire
attention il ne s'agit absolument pas de
conclure ici à mon deuil c'était mieux
avant il s'agit simplement de saisir
quelques apports du passé et de les
confronter à ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui
oki plus grand changement qui s'est
opéré concernant le pain date des années
50 ce qui est relativement récent en
effet de nouvelles technologies sont
apparues dans le but de produire du pain
en plus grande quantité 35% de la
production en france et industriels le
reste est artisanale mais ces deux modes
de production industrielle et artisanale
utilise une même farine dit standardiser
les améliorations technologiques dans ce
domaine et celles qui nous intéressent
se concentre principalement sur deux
choses le buttage et traitement de la
pâte le buttage ça consiste à tamiser la
farine
c'est une technique qui vise à améliorer
l'aspect de la passe c'est à dire que
l'on va blanchir artificiellement en
ajoutant des conservateurs pour lutter
contre les moisissures
ces techniques ont été inventés et
appliquée pour des raisons de
conservation durant transport et pour
des soucis de productivité dans les plus
grosses industries ont plus cure jusqu'à
maguette par heure sacrément et ça c'est
grâce à la modernisation des machines
sans elle impossible de faire autant pas
aussi rapidement et de nourrir autant
personne mais ce rendement est il si
bénéfique pour l'homme
est ce que cette modernisation est un
gage de qualité maintenant nous avons vu
dans les grandes lignes des modes de
fabrication du pain aujourd'hui nous
allons nous pencher sur les modes de
fabrication les plus anciens et pour
cela nous allons remonter dans le temps
au néolithique il ya environ dix mille
ans au proche orient lorsque l'on
commence à cultiver les céréales on se
met aussi à les broyer et pour ça on a
très vite besoin d'un outil qui
s'appelle la seule la meule c'est un
moulin manuel qui est utilisé pour
moudre le grain jusqu'à obtention d'une
farine on connaît la meule à va et vient
la meule rotatif qui seront remplacés
par le moulin à eau avant puis
aujourd'hui des moulins électriques
industriels très performant n'étant pas
ingénieur diplômé d'école central je
vais juste m'attacher à vous présenter
les phases d'élaboration et
d'utilisation de la meule truc de base
donc rapidement une meule c'est une
roche qui a une surface plane ou concave
dite active parce que c'est là que les
grains sont broyés comment utilise-t-on
une meule
c'est très simple on utilise une plus
petite pierre que l'on appelle broyeur
ou molette on dispose des grandes
surfaces et on vient écraser tout ça
avec le pilon cette action peut vous
sembler dépassée pour tenter sans doute
tous appris briser ce geste en cuisine
pour moudre poivre gros sel épices les
gestes de percussions qui comprennent la
mouture et broyage sont sans doute les
gestes techniques les plus anciens
notamment pour la confection des
premiers outils il y à plus de 2,6
millions d'années la percussion est
d'ailleurs l'une des salles techniques
utilisées par d'autres animaux que les
humains grands singes actuels brise les
fruits à coques à l'aide de pierres à
briquet utiliser une mais il ne sert pas
de tout repos geste répété durant de
longues heures créé des pathologies
sévères chez les utilisateurs de type
arthrose et déformations de la colonne
vertébrale sur le site archéologique
dabou herrera en syrie des huitièmes
millénaire avant notre ère
ces problèmes concernent exclusivement
les femmes dont les squelettes par ses
stigmates d'aussi fication de
l'articulation du genou déformations de
la colonne vertébrale et des formations
du premier métatarse due à une position
fléchie les orteils durant travail de
mouture donc l'idée de la pin up et
néolithique non
c'est pas possible ces constatations ont
conduit aux anthropologues envisager
qu'il avait là une division sexuelle du
travail et que le traitement des
céréales était une activité
principalement féminines de nombreux
récits ethnographique abonde en ce sens
dans la conquête du mexique de bernal
díaz del castillo
nous remarquons ce sont toujours les
femmes qui viennent apporter les vivres
et qui viennent moudre le maïs à partir
de là on peut se demander si la meule ne
serait pas le premier objet
d'asservissement de la femme fac avec la
modernisation au moins ça c'est terminé
on me laisse plus au travail
on a beaucoup moins de soucis de santé
on est bien équipé dans des recoins la
consommation des farines abîme également
les dents parce que pendant le travail
de mouture ya toujours des petits
résidus de roche qui viennent se
détacher et viennent se mélanger à la
farine fraîchement moulu voilà donc à
l'époque les mecs vous fait
véritablement des cailloux
pourquoi si on se ruine les dans le dos
et les genoux
on a tellement tenu à faire du pain pour
quoi les mecs ont tellement cherché à
moudre les graines n'ya pas manger les
céréales entières
l'action de mme houde revêt une
importance fictionnel capitale car
l'adduction des graines quand portion
petit et en farine les rend plus digeste
et plus nutritives
en somme plus un aliment est réduit en
fractions fine plus le corps en tir de
l'énergie et ça les hommes
préhistoriques l'avez certainement
compris les céréales constitue notre
principale source de vitamines b en
consommer régulièrement est un facteur
important de santé un pain élaboré à
partir d'une farine fraîche et d'une
valeur nutritive et gustative bien
supérieur à notre pain industriel actuel
et j'insiste sur le terme industriels
car il ya bien évidemment les artisans
boulangers qui font un pain de très
bonne qualité
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'un grain de blé une fois écrasé les
transformer cesse d'être vivants c'est à
dire qu'il perd sa composition primitive
il s'oxyde entre le viiie le quatorzième
jour après sa mouture ce timing n'est
absolument pas celui des industries
agroalimentaires qui ne transforme une
farine destinée au commerce qu'au bout
de trois semaines trois semaines ion
laquelle les nutriments disparaissent et
nous nous retrouvons ainsi dans notre
supermarché a hésité entre un pain de
campagne authentique et une baguette
française qui ne sont plus constitué que
de dieu cadavre de graines donc si les
paysans du siècle dernier et bien avant
eux les hommes du néolithique trimer à
moudre qu'ils ont tiré de ce dur labeur
un avis
en qualité nutritive vital le pain blanc
tirées d'une farine buté est un aliment
mort alors attention ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il est dangereux ou toxiques ça veut
simplement dire qu'il est inerte cette
dérive
le docteur catherine kousmine la mettait
déjà en avant dans les années 80 ans de
brouille en plus en achetant une farine
blanche ne consommons un produit
inférieur qui ne permet plus de garder
un état de santé et de résistance
remarquable
voilà c'était le premier épisode de
passer sauvage et de cette série dans
laquelle on s'intéresse à la question de
la modernité donc qu'il va y avoir
plusieurs vidéos sur ce thème je
l'espère dans tous les cas merci d'avoir
regardé j'espère que ça vous aura plu ça
vous aura intéressé et n'hésitez pas à
aller faire un tour sur mon blog
vous y trouverez un petit résumé un
petit texte en fait avec surtout mes
sources bibliographiques et toutes mes
références et puis il se passe d'autres
choses sur le blog et des articles
annexes vous invite chaleureusement à
aller cliquer sur passé sauvage points
comme je vous remercie une dernière fois
et je vous dis à la prochaine salut